I came out into the buzz saw of AIDS I
lived through the 80s and 90s watched
all my friends die and by 1985 almost
everyone I knew was dead or dying fast
forward to 2014 there's this new drug
that's available that allows you to take
some responsibility for yourself have
this pill come along when everybody was
still dropping dead yeah people would
have still lined up the consequence of
taking Truvada improperly is that you
contract a deadly contagious virus HIV
infection rates among young gay men are
appallingly high of rising so the
problem is people are gonna be out
breath they're gonna stop using condoms
we have something that's 98% effective
it's called a condom five out of six gay
men are not consistently using condoms
so it's not working there's a syphilis
epidemic and the gay male community and
if this experiment turns out badly well
the people who are promoting you take
responsibility for that
forty years ago the Castro Street Fair
was founded here in San Francisco at the
time homosexuals were fighting for basic
rights and recognition a decade later
the hiv/aids epidemic was ravaging the
community and there was a new battle to
be waged well over half a million people
in the United States alone have died
from AIDS
today drug cocktails keep many with HIV
alive and healthy but they are still
some 50,000 new HIV infections each year
two-thirds of which are among men who
have sex with men and a cure remains
elusive you know yes oh I have to tell
you yeah okay I don't
so prep stands for free exposure
prophylaxis taking a medication every
day
to help prevent HIV attacks why don't
too many people know about it that's the
question in 2012 researchers in a major
study estimated that Truvada a drug used
to treat HIV could be 99% effective at
blocking HIV transmission if taken daily
the preventative approach known as pre
exposure prophylaxis the same year the
US Food and Drug Administration approved
Truvada for use as prep but the drug has
proved to be a controversial weapon in
the fight to eradicate AIDS David and
Matthew are the DJ duo two dudes in love
an attorney and a marketing professional
with health insurance they can afford
Truvada as high price more than a
thousand dollars a month unsubsidized at
its heart at its core it's just about
keeping myself safe and making sure that
I'm not getting infected and that I am
not unknowingly infecting somebody else
the big criticism is that men will not
adhere to taking this pill adherence to
a daily pill is as natural as taking my
Flintstones vitamins in the morning it's
pretty easy for me because I take pills
everyday anyway I find it hearings is
really quite easy and focusing on
adherence seems like focusing on the
wrong part of the problem
Michael Weinstein is head of the AIDS
Healthcare Foundation in Los Angeles he
warns that promoting Truvada as a
preventative measure could lead to a
public health disaster pileup ominous
debate has been you can have your own
opinion you can't have your own facts
scientific data says unequivocally that
people who are taking this on
preventative basis will not take it as
directive you have something that's 98%
effective it's called a condom for 30
years we have pushed and pushed for
people to use condoms and it is it has
not guy on us to the end of this
epidemic and when we have a powerful
prevention tool like prep why would we
possibly walk away from that San
Francisco city supervisor Scott Weiner
represents the other pole in the trovato
debate he made headlines in 2014 when he
announced he was taking the drug good
and smart public health is about meeting
people where they are and helping them
as opposed to insisting and demanding
that people go to where you want them to
be the majority of gay men all right
using condoms we know that five out of
six gay men are not consistently using
condoms so the problem is prep is that
people are gonna be on prep they're
gonna stop using condoms and they're
gonna think they're protected when
they're not and they're gonna become
infected but to suggest we should not
make prep available wherever and for
whomever it will be effective is the
opposite of good public health if we see
a drastic increase in sexually
transmitted diseases because we've
attacked the condom culture that's been
prevalent for the gay community for all
these decades then that's a big problem
from the stigma sometimes attached to
Truvada that it promotes riskier
behavior and less condom use aroused the
derogatory term Truvada Hall
if you're on frontier promiscuous or
take more sexual risks but actually if
come to reclaim determines as users like
Adams Abbas key are the stigma he makes
these Truvada whore t-shirts now when I
mentioned the name Michael Weinstein why
oh god he has some fears
do you accept them as rational fears no
realistic sexual behavior just doesn't
match up with the idealized sexual
behavior that the condoms only crowd as
espouse for the last three decades and
the reality is that HIV transmission
rates are researching they're really
high and that the condoms only mantra is
not working it's not registering with
younger populations some of these guys
have tried to own the term they call
themselves Truvada whole is there any
argument in favor of calling these guys
Truvada whores in the derogatory sense
no I don't think you should call people
who take true Veda Truvada whores I've
met some whores who are on travail de
but I also know people who are in long
term Sarah discordant relationships who
are now free of the anxiety and also
freed from condoms we talk about
syphilis coming back and gonorrhea
coming back and not coming back we have
syphilis epidemic well yeah exactly
an epidemic and drug resistant gonorrhea
so prep is not a cure for that it's not
a prevention for that and it may make
that worse it may make both of the it
will make both of those epidemics worse
Dan Savage is a well-known author and
sex columnist
he's been cautious as he's waded into
the debate over prep well aware of what
the consequences of promoting it could
be I'm a faggot I know gay men I get
their letters every every day I know the
like calculus that we engage in before
we make certain sexual choices and
removing the fear of HIV which is
largely not a fear of death anymore but
a fear of stigma and convenience from
the equation will cause more guys to
indulge their legitimate desire to be
intimate in that way and
that is gonna make syphilis epidemic
worse absolutely one of the arguments
urging caution is that the young
generation don't quite know just how bad
it was and we don't want to slip back
into any form of recklessness right but
the young generation who already don't
know how bad it was are already very
spotty with their condom use and HIV
infection rates among young gay men are
appallingly high and rising so this
attitude that we should just knock the
prep out of their hands and deny them
access to this drug and that will
somehow inspire them all to start using
condoms when they're currently not using
condoms that's just idiotic there is a
generational divide in the debate over
prep and it isn't hard to find in the
Castro while younger men see it as a
viable option it's often those who've
lived through the AIDS crisis and
watched their friends die who are most
where
are you on breath now why not
about a thousand bucks a month
your generation thinks as a cure you
think that the tacos are chair
we know that this drug works the slogan
for my generation sadly was silence
equals death and it he pulled a lot of
death and I witnessed an awful lot of
death real misery Cleve Jones a longtime
leader in the gay community discovered
he'd contracted HIV at the age of 30 he
supports promoting prep we faced
horrendous stigma but the stigma came
from the outside world the young people
today are facing a much different and in
my mind much more pernicious stigma and
it's a stigma from their own gay
brothers saying how could you be so
stupid and I'm sick of it I'm just sick
of it as the debate over Truvada
continues the reality is that right now
it's an option only for those who can
afford it unless the price of prep comes
down or it is widely subsidized many in
the United States and more in the
developing world won't have the choice
to use it at all
you're seeing a lot of the debate
happening in middle-class gay largely
white communities who have access and so
the next question is how are we gonna
give access to everybody else and what
I'm hearing is no no cure no vaccine but
now we know that treatment equals
prevention so let's spread that word far
and wide and let's pressure the wealthy
nations to pay for it and let's pressure
the pharmaceutical companies to pay for
it and make it available to everybody
because what other option do we have
and for the debate to be settled it's a
matter of waiting to find out if access
to Truvada really does cut HIV infection
rates or whether more dire predictions
prove true if I'm wrong if HF is wrong
about this we'll be the first to admit
it but I hope that the people who are
promoting this will do the same I mean
in two years we'll know